julia flew in from zurich to join us and
has to catch a plane so Julia thank you
for joining us we're going to take a
short break so that Julian can get on on
her fact deserve and we'll continue our
conversation with Noah Julian thank you
so much thank you very much maximum
thank you very much fantastic questions
it has been fun great hi um so my
question is it pertain to Julia and the
social business when you put a
for-profit model to a non-profit model
you're essentially combining two
different notions and in one with the
selfs benefit aspect of capitalism and
the self-sacrifice notion of nonprofit
so how do you think that impact
investing in children businesses balance
that having to develop their selves with
having to promote social good looking
for the statement on capitalism this
self self service it's more of self
approximate yeah maximum you're
maximizing but i would i would challenge
that within the context of impact
investing which is that if you if you
are at all interested in i believe seek
a prior lads argument and you you see
this as a sort of symbiosis if you will
as an opportunity to combine both the
servicing of an unattended market with
social goods that otherwise that said
market would not have access to that
they needn't necessarily be mutually
exclusive